I think that people have seen this
highly demonized drug marijuana cannabis
you know a puff a party a tragedy that
that has now helped a lot of people and
that is sort of I think there's a
diminishing of the the Zeal for the drug
war there's a general sense and I think
that reason magazine and the
Libertarians and others have made a
really good effort over many decades to
help people understand that the drug war
is a really war against people and it's
tremendously unsuccessful and
counterproductive so I think a lot of
the suppression of psychedelic research
has been the concern that it sends the
wrong message that if these studies show
benefits then it gets in the way of the
drug war ideology so I think the drug
war itself has really lost credibility
and is seen as counterproductive so all
those factors I think make it so that
now we do have the Psychedelic
Renaissance